99% of people who use computers do not
know programming and they get stuck with
repetitive tedious tasks but these are
quite creative people and it is just
that programming as it exists today
creates an artificial barrier to program
computers program synthesis can allow
these end users to express themselves
naturally and program computers as
easily as they would command a personal
assistant you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
dr. sumit gowanni is a programmers
programmer literally a partner research
manager in the program synthesis or pros
group at Microsoft Research dr. Gulani
is a leading researcher in program
synthesis and the inventor of many
intent understanding programming by
example and programming by natural
language technologies today dr. Gulani
gives us an overview of the exciting now
and the promising future of program
synthesis reveal some fascinating new
applications and technical advances
tells us the story behind the creation
of excels popular flash fill feature and
how a flash fill fail elicited a viral
tweet that paved the way for new domain
investments and shares a heartwarming
story of how human empathy facilitated
an ah-ha math moment in the life of a
child and what that might mean to
computer scientists educators and even
tech companies in the future that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
sumit gowanni welcome to the podcast
Thanks kitchen it's great to be here so
I like to situate guests at the
beginning and you're a partner research
manager in the program synthesis or pros
group at Microsoft Research and you
describe yourself as a scientist seeking
connections between ideas between
research and practice and with people in
varied roles so in other words you're a
dock connector in broad strokes
tell us what gets you up in the morning
what X are you and the other members of
your group trying to solve for it is
simply the opportunity to what with the
fantastic team that I am part of we have
richest experts in programming languages
formal methods software engineering
machine learning and even human-computer
interaction we have researchers and
engineers working closely with program
managers and user experience designers I
am also terribly excited about the
charter of this team which is to advance
the state of the art in program
synthesis and to deliver these
innovations as magical experiences
across a wide range of Microsoft
products well we have a lot of ground to
cover today on the topic of program
synthesis so let's set the stage and
operationalize the term what is program
synthesis and why is it significant
program synthesis is any capability to
automatically generate programs or code
fragments from users intent expressed in
some natural form like input/output
examples demonstrations partial programs
or even keywords or natural language
this has the potential to facilitate two
disruptions first creation of 100x more
programmers because 99% of people who
use computers do not know programming
and they get stuck with repetitive
tedious tasks but these are quite
creative people and it is just that
programming as it exists today creates
an artificial barrier to program
computer
program synthesis can allow these
end-users to express themselves
naturally and program computers as
easily as they would command a personal
assistant this second disruption relates
to improving the productivity of
existing developers and data scientists
by 10 200x in many task domains most of
the code that these folks are writing is
simply boilerplate code and there is
very little algorithmic creativity
involved program synthesis can liberate
programmers from having to focus on
boring details and enable them to focus
on creative aspects of programming so
let me drill in a little bit there on
the claims of 100 X and 10 X - 100 X
increase in productivity and so on what
data do you have to support the claims
that this is gonna make our productivity
go way up we did some user studies
related to accomplishing a given task so
what took Python programmers around 30
minutes to accomplish was doable using
about program synthesis technologies in
less than a minute and this was quite
representative of the tasks in the space
of so-called data wrangling ordinary
leaning right so is this technology
being used and you're seeing it in
action and seeing these increases or is
it just on sort of research study end of
things right now in fact it is very real
the first mass market deployment of the
program synthesis technology was in the
form of this feature called flash fill
in excel which has been in Excel since
2013 and since then we have released
similar experiences based on example
based interaction across many different
Microsoft products well let's zoom in
and talk about flash fill which you just
mentioned and synthesizes string
transformation programs quickly with
minimal input/output examples sometimes
even just one tell us about flash fill
what inspired the idea in the first
place and tell us technically how you
went about building in those
efficiencies 10 years ago I was flying
from
Frankfurt to Seattle and there was a
lady sitting next to me in the airplane
she was impressed to know that I have a
PhD in computer science and that I work
for Microsoft Research
so I ought to help her with the task
that she was struggling with she opens
up a laptop fires up Excel shows me a
column of names in the format first name
is space last name and asks me how can
she reformat it in the form last name
comma first name now at that time I had
no idea about the programming model
underneath Excel so I do excuse myself
out of the situation after returning
home when I search for a solution to
that problem on Excel help forums it is
then that I realized that there were
many many people who struggle with
simple repetitive tasks and we solicit
the help of an expert on a Health Forum
while communicating your intent using a
few input-output examples a typical
interaction would take place over a
course of several days now this inspired
will develop the flash flow system that
can automate the role of the expert on
the Health Forum and bring down the
interaction time from a few days to a
few seconds the key technical aspect of
flash fill is the search strategy that
it uses instead of searching over a
general-purpose programming language we
restrict the search to an appropriately
design domain-specific language that
includes operators for string
transformations such as regular
expressions substring concatenate and
limited form of conditionals to allow
for dealing with data in different form
secondly instead of blindly animating
programs over this underlying DSL we
leverage logical properties of the
operators in this DSL to allow for a
goal-directed search so essentially we
flow the input-output examples down the
grammar of the DSL and this identifies
programs that are consistent with the
examples the third idea stems from the
observation that we also use several
heuristics to guide the search over many
choices that remain even after logical
reasoning has pruned most of the
possibilities in the search tree
authoring and maintaining these
heuristics has been an expensive
proposition
so recently we have actually started
using machine learning to learn these
heuristics from data that relates to
past exploration of the search space
over various benchmark tasks another
defining aspect of flash fill as you
mentioned is the fact that it can learn
the users intent from very few examples
right and it does this by ranking
programs to pick a candidate from among
them many programs that satisfy the
user's examples we prefer programs that
are a smaller simpler use fewer
constants use smaller sized constants we
also examine the output generated by
these programs on the other test inputs
that are available
we prefer those programs that generate
outputs that are similar and look
uniform for instance suppose we have one
program that generates all outputs that
are valid dates and another program that
generates mostly dates but also some
gibberish is stuff right then we have an
additional reason to prefer the first
program let's talk a bit about a
scenario where flash fill didn't work
I'll call it a flash fill fail tell us
that story and then tell us what you
learned as a researcher from that
experience flash we can automate a wide
variety of string transformations
however there are many transformation
tasks that it cannot do such as number
transformations or date transformations
but the user experience is so inviting
that people invariably want to give it a
try even on tasks that it was never
meant for and talk about it when it does
not work right so there was this recent
tweet on October 2018 that made fun of
flash film and was reciate more than ten
thousand times
twitter user darren wrote AI is going to
take over the word but look what Excel
auto populated for me today
Darren give an example converting DC to
December and flash will auto-completed
jn2 J number and Oct 2
my team found it funny enough to pin the
sweet on a t-shirt and now this t-shirt
is my dress shirt for my keynotes
the positive thing here is that this
kind of feedback has been extremely
useful for us to decide what new domains
to invest into for program synthesis
while we're on the topic of flash fill I
don't need to remind anyone that
Microsoft Excel is one of the planet's
most widely used software programs and
by extension as Ben Zorn points out the
spreadsheet is among the most widely
used programming languages
so we're firmly in product territory
here with Excel and you're firmly
planted in research territory how do you
manage the balance between academic
research and product engineering so by
the way Ben's on has been a great mentor
and collaborator and has shaped some of
my thinking on this topic the key is to
not treat this as a conflict the most
important bit that facilitates this is
to make thoughtful choices behind the
problem definitions that we pick as
researchers problems that will satisfy
our intellectual curiosity but will also
justify our corporate funding flesh will
was the most important turning point in
my career I went from instead of
searching for the hardest problem I can
solve to searching for the simplest
problem that will have the most impact
so I imagine program synthesis
technology applies or will apply in many
other cases besides Excel so what other
applications have you developed the
capabilities of program synthesis for so
we had developed program synthesis
capabilities for a variety of map
transformations I only talked about
string transformations number
transformations date transformations we
also develop these capabilities for
lookup based transformations and column
splitting transformations another area
that we are heavily invested in is in
the space of filter based
transformations and is specifically for
file ingestion normally you may spend
few hours writing parsers to extract
this information but programming by
example experiences allow you to simply
specify one to two examples of various
fields in the output table and the
parsers can be automatically synthesized
another related domain that we have
looked at is that of reshaping tables in
semi structured spreadsheets turns out
that 50% Excel spreadsheets are semi
structured meaning that data is logged
into some ad hoc format while this is
easy to visualize it becomes tricky to
analyze it we can enable reshaping of
these semi structured tables using an
example based experience where the user
can simply specify a few example tuples
in the intended output table so all of
these capabilities come under the broad
umbrella of so-called data wrangling
which is the task of transforming data
from one semi structured format to
another to facilitate for the downstream
processing data scientists apparently
spend 80% of their time wrangling data
bringing it into a form that they can
then build ml models over program
synthesis can facilitate easier and
faster data wrangling okay another
domain that we had developed some
synthesis capabilities for is that of
repetitive editing inside documents such
as Word PowerPoint or even code we are
also investigating development of
program synthesis from natural language
capabilities for several domains
including querying tables
visualisations and even machine learning
workflows so the scope for program
synthesis is quite broad simply given
that programming is so broad any task
domain where you can describe your
intent naturally is a potentially useful
candidate for program synthesis look
into the future then there are some
exciting new developments in program
synthesis that leveraged recent advances
in symbolic reasoning and machine
learning so tell us about these
developments and where we are heading
with these innovative threads of
research and what you call predictive
synthesis and modeless synthesis the
first prototype of flash field that I
developed would take three to four
examples on average or scenario the
Excel team told me that they cannot ship
flash fill and I made it work with one
example on most simple cases users would
lose trust in the system or would make
fun you know like that twit that I
showed you
recently I was challenged to do even
better now you might wonder how much
better can we be then one example I will
how about zero examples so initially
when this was proposed to me I thought
this was a crazy idea how can you read
the mind of the user from zero examples
you're reading my mind now just go into
my brain and decide what I'm thinking
but then when I thought more about it it
just started to make sense for some
domains consider for instance the task
of extracting tabular data from a custom
text file or a webpage sure enough you
know giving one to two examples of each
field is a much better experience than
having to write the parts of yourself
but if there are tensor fields then
giving one to two examples of each field
can itself be a tedious task but when I
show such a semi structured document to
human they can often guess the
underlying tabular structure so I
thought why can't mush into that so this
is what we call predictive synthesis
yeah the idea here is to synthesize an
intended program from several inputs as
opposed to few input output examples and
we enable this by learning or
synthesizing structure within the inputs
we have developed predictive synthesis
capabilities for a few domains including
splitting a column into multiple column
or extracting tables from text files web
pages and even PDF documents about
predictive synthesis capability for
extracting tables from text files ships
as part of sequel server management
studio where it is used to power the
flat file import wizard and apparently
now this is the most used wizard across
all of SSMS we also recently shipped our
predictive synthesis capability for
extracting tables from PDF documents and
from webpages as part of power bi
another new development is what we call
modeless synthesis there are many
mundane and repetitive tasks that users
may not even naturally think of as
something that can be programmed for
instance converting all red text to
green in a PowerPoint slide deck or all
dates in u.s. format to European format
in a Word document and this is where
there is a need for a personalized agent
that can non-intrusive Lee watch learn
and make suggestions so recently we
shipped an agent in preview mode in
visual studio that looks out for any
repetitive code edits when it identifies
a couple of code transformations that
can be related it generalizes them into
a more general script and uses that to
proactively suggest all other places
where I might need to make that edit
we've talked about the inner workings of
program synthesis but I'm really
interested in now what kinds of form
factors might be useful for different
applications of the technology so give
us an example of where and how someone
might make use of program synthesis and
on what kind of device most of the use
cases that I have talked about have been
for end-users to help them automate
their tasks one big leap that we are now
investing in is to synthesize a readable
editable program in a programming
language of choice this would be
especially important when the
synthesized program needs to be executed
on big data or deployed for future
executions hence we have been investing
in generating readable code in specific
target languages like Python our PI
spark and involving use of specific
libraries like pandas besides
facilitating transparency this
also provides lot of educational value
and most significantly would make it
possible to incorporate the synthesize
programs inside a developer or data
scientists existing workflow in IDs or
notebooks I'm terribly excited about
notebooks in particular program
synthesis is good about generating small
fragments of code which matches the
granularity of what users writing
notebook sells more what program
synthesis can generate readable code in
various target languages and using
various libraries and this shall address
the challenge that moo block users will
have around polygon programming and
discoverability issues around new
libraries and SDKs and notebooks provide
an ideal platform for that interactivity
so cross-disciplinary research is one of
four big bets you lay out in a blog post
from last year sumit and your own rather
prolific publication record in program
synthesis spans a surprisingly diverse
array of computer science conferences
and you've talked already a little bit
about diversity and multidisciplinarity
but I want you to go a little further
here and talk about why it's important
in research particularly as it relates
to program synthesis this is where the
Union adage one plus one equals eleven
that refers to the something more Danish
parts comes true now program synthesis
specifically is a highly
interdisciplinary topic we need serious
cross-disciplinary innovation to build
useful technologies and useable
experiences over those technologies this
has led to several publications in
programming languages in software
engineering conferences like purple P L
di
oops Linux C then we use machine
learning to learn various heuristics
that are difficult to author by hand and
maintain and this has led to
publications in conferences like ICML
and IC LR since all of this work falls
on another broad space of AI we have
several publications in triple AI and
each guy as well some killer
applications have been in the space of
data wrangling and because of the domain
relevance we have published in data
conferences like sigmod vldb and kdd
and last but not the least we'll have to
pay attention to usability issues as
well and this has led to publications in
HCI conferences like Western KY if you
think about the Graduate system that
produces us the emphasis is on creating
an individualistic identity preparing
students to define heart problems of
their own and to come up with solutions
of their own and they tend to become
deep experts in a narrow area it's a
very siloed exactly and then the natural
tendency is to continue exploration in
that deep vertical but I think it
requires a different kind of thinking
and leap to start appreciating the
importance of other research areas and
to figure out ways in which you can work
together enhance achieve results that
you would not have been able to produce
by yourself I think the goal of graduate
education should be to make you expert
in one narrow area but also give you
enough breath so that you know what is
the right tool and research area to be
applied to solving a given problem or a
sub problem so that you are not always
looking at it with your own biased lens
[Music]
whenever we talk about the promises of
innovative new technologies we also have
to talk about the perils and this is the
part of the podcast where I always ask
what could possibly go wrong I do this
because I want to know if there are
things we should be aware of or thinking
of or even concerned about when we
contemplate building and using these
highly complex systems you're talking
about that users will have very little
understanding of so is there anything
about your work sumit that keeps you up
at night so now that program synthesis
technologies are becoming mainstream the
increasing very on my mind has been that
of correctness how does the user know
that the program that has been
synthesized is correct right essentially
we need to start thinking about the
debugging experiences in this new world
of programming and I think that key is
going to be to regard program synthesis
not as a one-shot process but as an
interactive conversation with the user
in fact it turns out that when you do
not commit to a program yourself but you
rather program by intent we can actually
enable some unique debugging experiences
that are not going to be there in the
standard programming word we can for
instance synthesize multiple programs
from few examples each of those programs
is consistent with these examples of the
user provided and run all these programs
in parallel on the remaining test inputs
if they all produce the same result it
doesn't really matter which program you
pick but if these programs generate
different results on some test input it
is a sign of ambiguity in the users
intent on that test input and we can
surface that test input to the user and
ask them to provide the correct output
on that input this is one of my favorite
ideas and we call it distinguishing
inputs you can liken this to active
learning in the machine learning
terminology we published this idea in X
C 2010 and just few hours ago I learned
that this work has been selected for X C
2020 as the most influential paper for
the X C 2000
in addition I love stories tell us yours
sumit what was your path to computer
science and how did you end up doing
what you're doing right now Microsoft
Research
I finished my schooling in India and
then appeared for the Joint Entrance
Examination for IITs I managed an
all-india rank of somewhere between 100
to 200 out of around a million students
who take this examination why then was
sufficient to get me into computer
science but not in the city that was
closer to where my parents lived and
hence I had to make do with enrolling in
the electrical engineering program at
IIT Kanpur after taking the introductory
programming course in my first year
there I developed a love for the subject
the course instructor teased us that Oh
two by two matrices can be multiplied
with less than seven multiplications but
will tell us how unless I was in an
advanced class meant only for computer
science students so I retook the IIT
entrance examination and I managed a
two-digit rank in 30s I argued with the
university to promote me to the computer
science department for the second year
since the first year curriculum was same
for students in all the departments and
I had managed to prove that I deserve to
study computer science but they won't
agree so I decided to drop out and
reenter the university now actually
there is a ruling that would not permit
you to reenter the university like I did
so I had to repeat the first year and
was forced to take the same classes
again but I got to study what I loved
and that spurred me towards more
excellence in the field and hence PhD
was a natural choice right I was
fortunate to get PhD admission offers
from many top computer science
universities CMU called me and told me
that the cost of living here is so low
that I can even buy a house with my
GLaDOS - and Selvi I wrote to my advisor
George nebula at UC Berkeley and asked
him about a counter offer he said yes
the cost of living here is high but this
is because everything in the world wants
to live here
so now you make your choice so that's
how I landed up in Berkeley and then
after my PhD at Berkeley I had
like I'd make offers for faculty
positions but MSR was an easy choice for
two reasons the sheer amount of
cross-disciplinary talent under one roof
it is like many university departments
put together and the opportunity to
leverage Microsoft's broad reach to
customers to create real practical
impact almost every researcher I've had
in the booth has a sidequest I like to
call it or a personal passion and I know
from talking to you and from reading
some of your personal blog posts that
one of yours is inculcating human
empathy as an important cultural
attribute in the next generation so
circling back to your secret identity as
a dock connector tell us how you might
bring those two together there are few
principles that are being increasingly
embraced around our tech industry
customer obsession divorce workplace and
work-life balance these principles
relate to the three kinds of
relationships that we have in our lives
with our customers whom we serve with
our work colleagues and with our
personal contacts empathy holds the key
to understanding and nurturing this
relationship kids are highly attuned to
being empathic
I will tell you one story involving my
child's su-mei when he was in preschool
I wanted to teach him some conceptual
content and in particular a math theorem
I chose a theorem that relates odd
numbers odd plus odd equals even now
while it's a simple theorem the student
was a preschooler who had many more fun
things to do and this theorem was his
first the first evening I made all kinds
of diagrams but unfortunately didn't
work the next evening I tried using all
the various number related toys in the
house still no luck finally I realized I
had to meet so many where he was and not
pushed to a level that he wasn't ready
for hired the following evening I told
him a story an odd number is like a
group of guys that are all paired up
except one and he's a lonely guy
when duodenum birds come together then
the two lonely guys can pair up with
each other and become friends and that's
an even number suddenly I could see by
the look on his face that he understood
and bought it
and now I experience this firsthand when
summer was busy programming his robot on
his surface in the night and I tell him
suma it's time to go upstairs and sleep
and he's so engrossed he doesn't respond
and then I raise my voice and ask can
you please go upstairs now again no
response and then I tell so - sad voice
I'm going upstairs but I will be lonely
in the odd house up there can you join
me and make it even and then he
immediately comes to hold my hand and
says yes papa
let's go up that's bliss children are
naturally terrified of being abandoned
or gassed out and hence are very tuned
into feelings of either rejection or
belonging unfortunately our ability to
empathize gathers dust as we grow up
hence we need to reinforce this in our
school education and corporate trainings
a new aggression at the end of the day
the goal of Technology should be to make
a small human at the end of every
podcast I give my guests a chance to
share some advice or wisdom with our
listeners and I think you kind of just
did that so I'm gonna move over into the
predictive future lane what's on the
horizon for the future of programming
Submit and what might be a call to
action for our listeners if you look at
the history of programming we ventured
from punched cards and assembly language
to high level languages and beautiful
code editors the next evolution will
take programming closer to human
conversation involving use of examples
and natural language to express intent
and interactive when in computer will
act as your pair programming agent my
team is invested in developing an SDK
they can facilitate development of
program synthesizers for new task
domains I hope that with frameworks like
these we can take the art and science of
developing program synthesizers from
Microsoft Research laboratory's to
developers who are involved with writing
libraries or programming tools the grand
question now is what does this feature
mean for society programming in the
future would be much easier and
accessible than it is today
hence there should be even higher
incentive to incorporate so-called
computational thinking in the school
curriculum and this can empower people
to effectively leverage the
computational devices to unleash their
creativity and hence achieve more in
their lives
sumit Galvani thank you so much for
joining us on the podcast today it's
been an absolute delight the same year
Gretchen thanks for having me here to
learn more about dr. su Matt gowanni and
the latest in program synthesis research
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]